welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 13.
for today's episode i spoke with michael
malus
michael malus is the author of dear
reader and the new write
and the host of your welcome and
nightshade he's the subject of the book
ego and hubris by harvey picard
michael's a really interesting human
i was told to have him on the podcast by
dave rubin so i reached out to him
right away after our episode his book
dear reader
is an autobiography of kim jong-il
you heard that right he traveled to
north korea
and wrote an in-first-person biography
of kim jong-il
so we spoke about north korea and things
got pretty random after that
i sent him a personality test and he
showed up as zero percentile in
politeness
my dad has a personality test that i
absolutely adore
at understandmyself.com it's 10 bucks or
something and it gives you an accurate
portrayal of your personality
i also score a zero percentile in
politeness
but 89th percentile in compassion both
of those are facets of the trait
agreeableness and personality i believe
you can use the code michaela to get
some money off of it if you're
interested
or you can just give it to your
significant other to see if there's a
sociopath
also just so you're prepared i identify
as a libertarian
not a libertarianism please forgive me
oh audience enjoy the episode i don't
think i've laughed this much in eight
[Music]
months
[Music]
okay michael malus welcome to my podcast
thank you so much for
coming on thank you so much for having
me uh
so i get started usually with a podcast
with getting the guests to tell
my audience a little bit about them like
who who are you
um well i was let's see i
am the subject of a book by the late
harvey picard
the book's called ego and hubris uh i am
an author
uh people know me from my previous book
dear reader the unauthorized
autobiography of kim jong-il which is
the entire history of north korea in one
easy to read format
my most recent book was called the new
right a journey to the fringe of
american politics
which described the anti-progressive
coalition that culminated
in a sense of the trump victory and that
still maintains a lot of cultural
influence today
um and i am a twitter troll
i think and a lifelong new yorker i
think that's kind of the um
uh that covers pretty much oh and i host
two shows uh you're welcome with michael
malus
and nightshade which is on my weekly
nightly news wrap-up show on compound
media
okay i i brought you on because i had a
podcast with dave rubin and he said you
have to get michael malus on
and i didn't know of you before he said
you have to get michael malus on
um and i just well i didn't know of you
either
so how's it feel
well i i did a bit of scrolling through
your twitter
um and no like
you're not sorry you're just saying i'm
trying to be canadian
oh okay well you don't have enough drawl
in this story
it's sorry all right i'll figure it out
uh
anyway you're i definitely know you well
i don't i didn't know of you
but going through your twitter i can
definitely see you're a troll
so i wanted to start a bit
with that and i guess how do you judge
do you care if what you're trolling is
appropriate or if you're hurting
people's feelings or do you
think that what you're doing online
the people that you're bothering online
are worthy of bothering
well worthy is can have a lot of
different meanings
if you think if you're asking is it you
should you feel bad about
uh hurting people who deserve to be hurt
the answer is no there's two types of
people in this world there's
superman and batman and superman's job
is to help the good people and batman's
job is to hurt
the bad people and i think there's a lot
of nastiness and toxicity
in social media and some people only
respond
to speaking their own language now
at the same time if i'm clowning you on
twitter that's not nefarious like we all
anyone who has some healthy self-esteem
will enjoy being the subject
of a joke uh and will be entertained by
it
so i think trolling has a and trolling
is
in the term and i use trolling in a
pretty specific way not in the sense
just being a jerk uh because as as terms
reach the mainstream they lose their
kind of specificity
i use trolling to mean exploiting
someone's weaknesses to turn them into
an unwitting performer
and trolling is a very effective
mechanism towards
eliminating power hierarchies because a
lot of people who presume
to have authority over you or presumed
to have dominance or power
it's a bluff and when you call them on
your crap and you expose them
very quickly any such power is
removed and this is also useful
mechanism because people like that are
very effective at
bullying others so if you can kind of
pull their pants down and have them
be exposed it's a very useful social uh
technique as well
yeah that's fair i wrote a paper on not
a paper uh
an article on trolling uh i got totally
destroyed like last september
from i don't know if you can even call
like vegans i guess anybody can troll
but i got attacked by
somebody with a huge vegan following so
i wrote an article on
what trolling was and why it it's
effective
and comedic and it depends right because
there's trolling and then there's just
being an [ __ ]
yeah there's no there's no creative way
yeah yeah which is different
yeah absolutely yeah yeah well your
twitter is very entertaining well thank
you
and like necessary i think
yeah i i i i enjoyed it immensely and
as my platform has gotten bigger and
bigger it's
given me bigger and bigger targets to
work with and within to the amusement of
many
and to the detriment of some yeah yeah
fair okay so one of the things i got
i'm interested in i think mainly is your
experience
in north korea you wrote a book about it
well
an uh biography but autobiography
is it yeah it's kim jong-il's it's right
here it's kim jong-il's
um there we go it's kim jong-il's life
story is told from his words so what i
did is
uh i went to north korea and i got all
their literature
and kim jong-il in north korea he's kim
jong-un's father
and his father kim jong kim song was the
founder of north korea
uh he's there for his gum so anything
that happened in north korean history
according to their mythology he was
there and he was a witness to
so by having him tell his story he's
effectively telling the reader
the entirety of north korean history
from their perspective
and it was very grueling to put this in
kind of a very
beach read i wanted to be light because
most of the literature about north korea
is either too
academic or it's too intense i mean
this is the worst place on earth the
things they do to their population is
nightmarish so to have it be this kind
of light farcical tone
was very hard and to have all that
information packed in there was
no mean feat so
how did that come about like how did you
end up doing that
going to north korea in the first place
you've never been it's the new milan
no i was on my friend ed who i went to
college with
who i am going to take every opportunity
to disdain because it turned out when we
were in college he spread the rumor that
i had aids
i only found out about this years later
um i was on his facebook it's not true
in remission
i was on his facebook and it was his big
dopey face in kim wilson square with the
north korean tanks behind him
and i'm like what is going on and he
said yeah it's legal
like he had met a guy in burning man of
course and there are tours
where it's illegal now but at the time
you just got to give them a ton of money
and you're allowed to um be a tourist to
north korea now
this was uh something that they fought
kicking and screaming
during his lifetime uh kim jong-il said
we don't want hordes of tourists coming
in here
uh bringing forth pollution and
spreading aids that's an actual quote
from him
but after the end of the cold war when
north korea was no longer a welfare
state of china and the
soviet union they had very little to
offer the outside world
and they needed hard currency um and one
of the few things that they could do is
bring people over there and show them
around so it was legal
i went there in 2012 you know i i
this is the kind of thing people say all
the time but i think people will forgive
me for the cliche
it is a life-altering trip especially
because
every single person who i saw everyone i
saw
is still there i still see my guide on
instagram they're all prisoners
of this you know nightmare regime so
when you realize how much your life has
changed in the last eight years anyone
listening to this think about it
and they're all trapped uh you start to
understand that when it comes to north
korea the only issue at hand
isn't trump it isn't his kim jong-un's
sister is
what does this mean for the continuing
enslavement of the 25 million north
korean people
who had in the past been regarded as a
bit of a laughing stock
thanks to my work and many others people
have kind of
understood now that this is perhaps
humorous in the sense of absurdity
but not humorous in the sense that these
are silly people putting on a show
because they realize wait a minute if
someone put a gun to my kid's head
i'm going to be putting on a song and
dance real fast and proudly so
and i'm not even going to hesitate
yikes yeah
so do you think part of the reason you
do the
well trolling on twitter is
i mean this might sound a bit dramatic
but the way
things are going politically in america
i've had people
who were in the ussr reach out to me
anyway and say
hey some of the actions that people are
doing now
seem similar to what was going on in the
ussr so do you think part of the reason
you're trolling is because of your
experience
in north korea or have you always been
kind of humorous and pokey
i was born the ussr so i'm very familiar
with what they're saying
and i would disagree because i would
argue that the ussr techniques have been
here for decades
and it is now only that that mask has
been dropping and people are more aware
that this sort of duplicity and
chicanery has been going on in the
states for a long time
we are simultaneously told in the states
that mccarthyism
which is the one time that leftists were
cancelled was the darkest thing that
ever happened
in america but also the era that is most
necessary to emulate we're being told
with a straight face that the senate
majority leader
is da and the president are both taking
orders directly from moscow
and no one seems to find this ironic or
have any pushback
to make these kind of brazen uh claims
whereas at the time when there were
people
who were taking orders from stalin with
the gulags with the holodemour
with the secret police and trying to
install stalinism
in this country the fact that they
couldn't get gigs as screenwriters
were is still portrayed as the greatest
injustice in history
i mean that's the level so this is not
new uh that's the level of depravity
of what we're up against and thankfully
thanks to social media just like zames
dada in the soviet union
when you have a democratization of
information and a democratization of
reporting
and exchange of ideas it is very hard
to have a monopoly monopoly narrative
and monopoly control of history
and the present day and we see it an
example of this
is the new york times which is very much
an enemy agent
they are explicitly and publicly
engaging in a coup
against our nation's history with their
1619 project
they are redefining and i'm using that
term advisedly
america as having been founded with the
founding act being slavery
now if you are going to say and this is
a valid position from their perspective
that america is a nation that is
definitionally
about slavery a lot of your argument is
taken care of
because everything else just follows
suit like dominoes
so the fact that they are having to do
this publicly
the fact that people are calling them
out on their crap including many
historians including many leftist
historians
is a great example of why i'm very
optimistic
about the future of our country they
have to now
engage in their antics under the full
daylight
of social media which they cannot uh
abide that's actually a really good
point
that's actually no that is a really good
point though because like
well my dad's been on about he got made
fun of a couple years ago about
um like marxism making its way into
society and everyone's like oh
like that's not real but um
yeah that that totally makes sense and
at least now
there is social media and you can't
censor it well
you can censor it but it's much more
difficult to censor right
right okay so back back to north korea
um do you like in your book do you have
any suggestions
about what can be done or is there
anything that can be done for that kind
of regime
uh i i am someone let me
bring up an example i recently learned
from marianne williamson who was a
presidential candidate
uh in 2016 2020 she's regarded as new
age she's this kind of self-help guru
and i read her book and she had
something in it that i found
extremely profound she was a
speaker in la during the 80s during the
aids crisis and she has a very
disproportionately gay audience
a lot of gay men came to her classes and
they were dropping like flies
and she was in a position as this you
know healer
to try to offer them hope when no one
cared when there was no cure on the
horizon
when men at age 27 the prime their life
are dropping likewise
i mean to have hope for this is kind of
an absurdity it's going to look
you know fallacious on its face and what
she said to them
she goes how about this how about
instead of saying we're going to get a
cure tomorrow
what if we get it to the point where
it's like diabetes
right you're going to live a long life
they cut off your feet you go blind
is that unrealistic should people
diabetes just kill themselves
if we get to is that really that nuts so
and i i bring that up all the time
because that's such a great way of
having hope and looking at realistic and
possible uh
futures if you tell someone who's
homeless like you know a you know heroin
addict
like you're gonna be a millionaire
you're gonna be a lawyer or doctor cool
cool
if you tell them you know what you might
have to have a sucky job and have a
roommate you don't like
uh for a year it's like oh i could do
that
that's not really so bad and compared to
what i have now
that's a miracle so in terms of my
my book bringing this back to north
korea i have no idea
all i knew how to do as an author and
someone who knows how to run his mouth
is to take where the camera was on kim
jong-un
and kim jong-il as clown figures and
move it a little bit and i say it's like
the joker in you know batman
look at this clown but behind that clown
you have lots and lots of corpses
with the blood on his hands and that's
where the focus
the literal focus of that camera needs
to be not on this clown
by the people behind him what happens
next i have no idea
and i can think of many reasons why
there isn't
good options there are no good options
for north korea including for the north
korean leadership
because it's like riding a tiger when
you take your hand off of that tiger
you're the first one who's going to
personally have a bullet put in you and
with good reason
so it's bleak all i knew how to do
is provide information and try to
encourage both
empathy and sympathy for the north
korean
population which is very easy for us in
the west to
dismiss both because of this low-key
anti-asian racism
asians are weird and the fact that so
few people escape out of there to be
able
to speak for them and once you kind of
start talking to people
just on a very basic level it's if i
found it's
very quick how people snap out of it and
they're like oh my gosh this is
horrible how did i ever you know look at
this with any sort of
bemusement yeah
a couple of years ago i don't remember i
think it went viral online but it was
a cartoon from people who had left north
korea
and it was cartoon drawings of what
they'd experienced in north korea
um i i don't remember when it was maybe
2014 or something
um and it was horrible
and i like i sent it around to some of
my friends because it was
horrible and some of them were like no
that's not there's no way that's real
it's like that's like that and the thing
people need to understand
is they are not robots it would be a lot
easier if it worked and they had all
been dehumanized and it's like a country
of androids
but the fact that i know refugees and
they're the most vapid boring people you
ever want to meet just like everybody
else makes it
you know all i ask for the north korean
population is that they have a recliner
that they can sit in
filling with their farts like the rest
of us watching stupid television and
having
their beer that's it they don't need to
have you know spaceships
they don't need just food and not to
have to be afraid
of that knock on the door in the middle
of the night um
and when you realize that these are
human beings with i did a article about
my trip for reason magazine i called it
my week in north korea
and the first line was how do you make a
north korean laugh
they have a great sense of humor and a
dark set i mean the refugees have a very
dark sense of humor i met one refugee
and she said her favorite movie and book
was the hunger games because she's like
oh it's like being back home how did
they know
what it was like and i'm like am i
allowed to laugh at this um
another refugee i knew it was it was
just amazing about the human mind and
just
speaking more broadly i we were walking
in new york
and it was one of those new york winters
and the winds were through you know just
insane and
you know we're trying to get to the
train and i turned to him and i'm like
weren't you homeless for a year living
on the mountainside
and it's amazing and he had been and
i mean your reality can change from that
is the normal to now that it's like oh
it's 30 degrees
i can't bear this it's just fascinating
to see how easily
and quickly they transition to a
normal liberal sense of life and that
should give us all
hope but that should also pain us that
this
is being done to this population and
it's a country
where by law it's family
punishment the great leader kimbo song
that class enemies must be exterminated
to three generations
so if someone commits a crime in north
korea three generations of your family
are punished
and you don't know who did it so
it's we there's so many levels of hell
and i go through it in the book because
this didn't happen overnight this was a
systemic laying
of oppression by this family over this
nation for decades
and little by little they they just
twisted the screws twisted the screws
twisted screws
and ended up with the situation that uh
they have today it's
it's it's there's nothing else like it
it's really bothering to me also just to
ramble a little bit
when you hear western analysts and they
try to conflate it with china
or try to conflate it with russia or you
know iran or something like that
it's like it's its own unique animal
this is something they boast about how
unique they are
uh but when you sit down and you study
what has been done
to this nation it it's just
mind-bogglingly chilling
so how did you learn all this i mean i
can't it can't just have been
like what was your week there like was
your week there chilling
it's impossible first of all there's no
internet access there's no access to
outside information
right so and they take your cell phones
at the plane at the airport there's no
way to convey to anyone else and it's
hard for me to even explain
what it's like to be in a country with
no
access to the outside world with no
ability to have an atm
the internet news time the headlines are
the same every day
dear leader opens up you know new farm
there's no sense of time
it's not possible to convey what that's
like
where every day is the same and it's
it's almost like dreamlike in a way um
it's very disturbing uh
i mean when you're in a capital city
pyongyang is their showcase city they
they
have such like a social credit score
which determines where you can live in
the country
so people who aren't uh reputable in the
government's eyes aren't allowed to even
step foot in the capital city right
so these are the best the best but
you're in a capital city with
skyscrapers they don't really have
electricity
it's just so weird to see that you know
at night where these buildings are half
lit
it's it's and the thing is because it's
a um
artificial nation it's you know it's
central planning everything you see
is there by design right but like any
other city but that's more decentralized
and you're looking around and you're
trying to have things that are analogous
to what you've experienced or maybe
you've experienced other countries
and some things you you oh okay i know
why this is like this
but others you know you're not gonna be
able to make heads or tails of it and
you're not really going to be in a
position to ask for explanations either
interesting was there so there was
nothing
how do i ask this like was there
anything fun on your trip
or was it just creepy oh it was a lot of
fun the people
try to do their best to have happiness
in this most unhappy place and what i
did
being a obnoxious brooklynite uh
is every single person i saw i got in
their face and waved
because i knew as a tourist i'm allowed
to get away with being
a jackass but what that showed me
because not everyone's good at improv
was sincere reactions from the
population
and people waved back girls giggled
grandmas you know with their grandkids
you know hugged them close were very
proud look at her
teenage boys with their adidas track
suits rolled their eyes and turned their
heads
but you saw the entire gamut of
perfectly universally expected human
behavior
um so there was i i oh here's the thing
this is my tip i wrote my article i'll
tell everybody else
if you go to north korea just take every
racist joke you know
and replace the punch line with japanese
and they will be on the floor
in hysterics because their loathing for
the japanese is pervasive
so if you say how do you stop a japanese
man from drowning
take your foot off his neck oh they will
just
be crying laughing every single joke you
can think of just take it and put
japanese and then
because the the people don't understand
the west their entire mythology
is based on racial purity uh and that
the korean race is the only
pure country on earth every other
country has been
mixed um and this they're so in many
ways they're far closer to
fascists than they are to communists
how do they feel about south korea
though south korea so north
north and south korea they regard as one
country that is indivisible and that
korea has been the first country on
earth
korean was the first language ever
spoken korea was the first government
so since korea is one that's their
slogan whenever you're in north korea
they show a map of korea as one unified
country
and they write north korea with a lower
case n south korea with the lower case s
because south korea is not a separate
country it is a region
under occupation by the us imperialists
now by law
whenever they refer to the japanese or
to americans they have to use a slur
so it's very it was very funny to me
when i was reading their books
and they'll be talking about history but
it'd be like in 1905
the wicked [ __ ] devils blah blah blah
blah blah and it'll be
but like that's how they talk or the the
yank bastards or things like this so
it's a mechanism of social control
whereas
you can't talk about these other
populations um
indifferently even if you wanted to it's
built into the language and the jargon
itself
so they have an enormous affinity for
the south korean people in fact one of
the people on my tour with me
was of korean descent and in north korea
it's very big on culture to
have these over displays of emotion
that's not fake
and you know one of the people we met
was crying she's like i feel like i'm
meeting my son
because you have to also appreciate
these two nations have been separated
since the 1940s
including some families and anyone who
goes on youtube and looks of korean
family reunions
people haven't seen each other for
decades fathers and daughters brothers
you are going to cry your eyes out at
how disturbing it is
that these families have been separated
the only reason
is the evil north korean regime keeping
them from contacting their family
members and even worse
if they are talking to foreigners that
is extremely politically suspect and
have can have
profound consequences for you and your
family
that's so awful like you can talk about
it but
being separated from your family and not
able to contact them
just that is so awful uh it gets even
worse so i'll tell you another story um
there was a north korea is engaged in
lots of terrorism and provocative
behavior over the decades
at one time they send a hit squad to
south korea to the blue house where the
south korean president lives
in an attempt to murder him uh the north
the south korean security guards you
know got wind of this
they took out most of the north koreans
um shot them
one guy saw what was happening when
north korea and he stayed behind
and he just got captured by the south
koreans uh
rat because he didn't kill himself or
you know die in the line of duty they
took his parents
in north korea took them into a stadium
and she publicly executed them as a
lesson
for him so it's
however bad you think it is like people
think it's bad because they have to
learn stupid things at school
and perform in a play once a year like
if it was just that
it would be a paradise compared to what
they have to go through
that's well no wonder that sounds like
the hunger games
yes yes it's it's and the fact that this
is happening on our earth
the fact that they have concentration
camps that you can see right now in
google earth
um and you know we always talk in school
how did the holocaust
was how is that allowed to happen well
you know they've got 200
000 people roughly in these camps right
now and no one knows what to do about it
and i'm not saying
people have an easy answer they don't
but the first step is to be like
guys this is this is happening right now
and this is
has been happening for a long time um
and the least you can do
is just have some sympathy uh for this
population which most people do to be
fair
yeah or at least admit it's happening
um so what's this uh generational
punishment
can you delve into that a little bit
sure so again
uh this is a very kind of old-school
asian idea that you know families are
responsible
instead of having this western kind of
individualism right so
in the camps it's written on the walls
you know the class enemies must be
exterminated
through a few generations um
and i i don't know that there's not much
more to explain they don't really have
this kind of court system there's no
miranda rights you know they're not
brought in front of a court and you have
some kind of you know legal defender uh
basically you know the order comes down
and three generations get taken
and people get sent to the camps and the
scary thing is which is shocking for us
to believe
a lot of people who go to those camps
aren't sent there for life they're sent
there for a finite period and then
they're allowed to reintegrate into
north korean society
they have to sign an nda but some of
them you know break it and there's a
book
called aquarius of pyongyang about
someone who escaped who
was from pyongyang a very prominent
family got sent to the camps then was
later
uh released and uh some people remember
during the
early 2000s george w bush had the axis
of evil as iran
iraq and north korea and north korea
took great umbrage at this because
they're like what do we have to do with
iran iraq
and part of the reason he had such a
contempt for that country correctly is
because he had read that book and it was
so
disturbing to him as it would be
disturbing anyone who reads it it's just
uh um just shocking what sort of things
happen
to people uh in that country
okay well that's horrifying yeah and so
they don't allow people in anymore
well no now that america banned it so
they still do allow people in
um they're still i mean they have a lot
of tourism from china
uh they don't get along particularly
well with the chinese tourists because
the chinese tourists
apparently treat them kind of like like
um uh like rednecks
and and trash and talk down to them so
this is a source of contention
uh and they have so but still they're
they're not doing so hot let's just put
it that way
wow okay well anyway that was fun
um it's a hoot yeah that sounds
yeah not not good um but let's switch
topics then let's like
north korea yeah is not a hoot um how
did you
get i would put you in the category of
people who are involved in the
intellectual dark web am i officially
inducted i don't know dave rubin said
like get michael malus on your podcast
and
i just assume anyone who's involved with
him could be put in the idw class
really you think candace owens is idw
i don't know how i feel about canis
owens okay this is off topic
but have you have you seen and i want to
know what your opinion on this have you
seen what's been going on with
chrissy teigen on twitter oh yeah
okay what are your thoughts on that uh
a follower of mine had a great tweet
which is that pizzagate aged better than
russiagate
um i think we s what we saw with jeffrey
epstein
and amy rohrbach with abc news should
have
shaken everyone to their core and been
profoundly disturbing when she's
you know caught on a hot mic talking
about how they had the receipts on
everybody
we know for a fact that there's been
this kind of international child sex
trafficking i don't i don't at all
suspect chrissy teigen of being involved
in any capacity i've been following to
that extent
to be fair but i do want to make clear
that
it's and this is another thing coming
from being born the soviet union
america and i made this point in rogan
americans have this very naive idea
about what corrupt power means they
think it means i'm gonna hire my brother
as a construction gig and pay him double
the money
and get rich that way or like hunter
biden that's not what it means
corruption means doing things that if we
learned about it
we would all consider it just absolutely
depraved
and that they relish in the fact that
they're getting away
with this depravity a great example of
this is which is not
in dispute so no one can get upset about
this in that sense
is roman polanski he drugged and raped
an underage girl
he fled to florida excuse me to france
to escape punishment in the united
states
and he's still not radioactive in
hollywood
i mean that in and of itself should make
everyone scratch their head and be like
wait a minute
paula dean's career was ruined because
she used the worst racial slur decades
ago
he drugged and raped an underage girl
and you are still talking about this guy
as if he's a badass
and when you see that it's like okay i
don't know what's going on behind closed
doors
but i know that it's not the kind of
thing where i could roll my eyes and
shrug my shoulders at
yeah that's fair i have no idea what's
going on there
i i looked at chrissy teigen's tweets
and i thought
okay she's got i think she's funny i got
like
i don't know if i'm allowed to say that
but like i think she's funny and
her tweets they're like in 2011 nobody
cared about them because people just
thought they were funny and now
it's like oh she mentioned a kid and now
there's this thing to jump on so
going back to candace owens like i think
i think she's great for speaking her
mind but also
i i wasn't really on board with whole
like
cancer basically trying to can't like
the right-wing people trying to cancel
chrissy tegan and chrissy teigen may be
she's like annoying in some respects but
she's also funny and she's also just a
person and
i'm not a fan of canceling anybody
regardless of especially for tweets
like a while ago that were kind of funny
anyway that's my opinion on that it's
like i don't know if i like chrissy
teigen but some of her tweets were funny
and she's just getting destroyed by
right wing like
super right-wing trolls i would say on
twitter
like destroyed she deleted 28 000 tweets
and people are like oh that proves that
she's a pedophile
i was like maybe she doesn't want to be
attacked on every thread
like yeah you know like even if you're
on your phone while you're taking a dump
and you have a thought
like you don't need to bring it up nine
years later be like what did you mean by
this
i meant i was in the bathroom
right i was like you can't even delete
them they still
exist freaking twitter i hate twitter
it's growing on me it's like the older i
get the more i like twitter i don't know
what that says about twitter or me
but slowly moving from instagram to
twitter
i i'm not an insta fan because i'm not
verified on instagram so
you know f them and plus i don't like
that they tell you what you can and
can't see
i want to see everything for everybody
in chronological order that's it
it's not hard and instagram doesn't
allow you that
do they order things they disorder them
instagram and also they won't show you
everyone's pictures
see i don't know anything about this
yeah but twitter so [ __ ] they claim they
don't shadow band they do but it's
nowhere near the extent that instagram
does it
really yeah
facebook's the worst facebook's the
worst they have no pretense that they're
going to show you
a lot of things and and the fact that
you can't even have that as an option
is why i left facebook i'm on reuben's
site locals mouse.locals.com
specifically for that reason i think
facebook has become increasingly what
people say twitter is
uh in the sense of being very toxic and
a place where people engage in really
vitriolic arguments and it's even worse
because it's from people who are
connected in some capacity and i think
that's very bad for mental health
i think it is uh demented to judge
the quality of your relationship with
someone based on your shared political
views it's kind of like when you're in
junior high
and think i'm going to go out with this
girl because we like the same music
i mean it makes sense when you're 14
when you grow up you're like this is a
very weak metric
for determining the quality of a
relationship
yeah so you think facebook's worse than
twitter oh by far
really just because there's a connection
between people yeah
i i think yes i think it's also more
argument focused because you can go on
these big speeches
i think it's um and on twitter everyone
is this egalitarianism about it about it
which i usually am averse to
but the fact that i can you know call
out lauren's tribe as just this
nasty demented old man to his face and
there's nothing you could do about it
is really kind of amazing whereas on
facebook it's very easy to have your
settings so only your friends can
comment
ah okay that's funny i have a different
experience
like um i i find uh just for the social
medias i'm on
i found face i don't go on facebook
really like my main
platform probably is instagram and then
now that i'm doing podcasts
youtube i like youtube um but
facebook i found was more personal so it
was if anyone was going to attack me it
was friends and that would hurt more
yes um but twitter
like it's hard to manage to mute
enough people are you gonna get like
oh i just i just mute them i don't know
they're driving away the people you want
you do you flush the toilet or do you
leave it there and close the lid
you have to create your own bag so i
suppose yeah i know but then doesn't
that
yes but i feel like that kind of like
swerves into
censoring a little bit like i don't i
don't want to delete that if that's what
people
think i just want to see it because it
makes me feel ill
freedom of association is integral to
mental health
it's integral to self-progress and it's
you know if you have a party you have a
guest list maybe a friend of a friend
but if someone comes in there and
they're being obnoxious there are people
whose only role
is to spread toxicity and aggressive
banality
if you're going to be aggressive be
creative about it if you're going to be
contrarian or
argumentative bring something on the
table if not
it's going to alienate the people that
you want surrounding you
i've had a great experience on twitter
because of this and i advocate for this
very heavily
and my audience like when i do my shows
you know people come on they're always
surprised the quality of the interaction
from my crowd
because yeah i very heavily feel the
need to weed my garden
and to keep out people who i do not have
a presumption of interaction
my presumption is of uh disinterest
and separation i don't think most people
have anything to bring to the table
how did you get to that because i like
that's not how i viewed people
at all until i don't know only recently
i guess i started talking to people
thinking that they were actually
different from me it took me at least
until i was 20
i would say like only a year ago so 27
until i realized oh people aren't the
same as me
i i literally went around thinking
assuming people were the same as me and
turns out
i'm [ __ ] weird which i didn't know
until i was 27. so how did you get to
the point where you realized
i don't know what the average person is
like uh
well i went to yeshiva as a kid i was an
immigrant and when you go
to yeshiva and you know you're raised in
a certain kind of
ideological mindset and then you go from
there to public school which i did in
fourth grade
and i then i learned what like and
because the focus was so scholarly so
much in education and so much you know
and certain things
and then i went to public school and i
saw what the average person was like i
was like holy crap it was a very
kind of disturbing thing and then also
to when you hear
um uh i always i've always been an
outlier so i've never felt
normal i didn't regard it i sometimes
it's a bad thing sometimes it's a good
thing
um but the kind of things that you see
people say politically
you know with a straight face and just
repeat
uh once you notice it and take that red
pill you can't
un-take it uh and then it just is it's
like oh okay
it's very liberating when you realize
you don't owe anyone an explanation
or engagement or any kind of interaction
and that the odds are going to be pretty
low
that you're going to get anything out of
an exchange other than having them as a
source of amusement
wow i'm still definitely not at that
level
but you get there you're young yeah
right i'm not as jaded as i should be i
don't know why
it's not jaded it's not being jaded you
just i realized
yeah you eat at the best restaurants you
read the best books
i mean those books are rarer but that
doesn't mean that they're
uh those it's just it's just a statement
of uh
of fact i mean to expect people to not
be otherwise is
is something we're trained to believe
but is not based on uh data
like if you go to a bookstore right
ninety percent of those books are crap
that doesn't mean those ten percent of
the only ones that matter
those ten percent of the books are what
validate all literature
doesn't mean he's not making jaded it's
just you know kind of like what's it's
not a numbers game i'm not a
democrat in either sense
i don't know i just assume and i think
i'm wrong i really do think i'm wrong
but i
i assume that everybody i talk to
like i said is the same as me so i i've
got quite a bit of drive to work and to
earn money and to read and to learn and
i want a really strict diet and like i'm
i'm fairly
disciplined and so i meet other people
and if they're not as disciplined i just
automatically am annoyed
like well why aren't you trying harder
and sometimes is because they're
literally not as disciplined it's not
their fault
they just are that way i've i've given
many talks and when i advise the kids i
say
don't aspire to excellence because
that's not going to be something that
you're capable of
with your age agent experience and data
aspire to competence
if you are confident you are at the 80th
percentile if not 90th percentile
because if you're working for me and you
say i will have it wednesday
and you have it wednesday i would rather
have that than you say i'll have it
monday and give it to me tuesday
even though that doesn't make sense on
one level so when you think in those
terms
the amount of people who are like if
they screw things up majorly
instead of feeling guilt just shrug
their shoulders and say
well everyone makes mistakes well yes
that's factual everyone makes mistakes
everyone has flaws
the fact that you're using this as a
justification for any individual mistake
uh that you might make renders you as a
horrible person another example like
i need people to give these talks and
they'll say oh i'm terrible with names
well what yeah no one's great with names
what have you tried
to you have a flaw you've identified you
have a flaw what have you tried well
i've tried nothing
so clear it's like seriously you can't
go from terrible to just
mediocre with names like that's not in
your capacity
i used to be a huge procrastinator now
i'm not
but one day i sat down and i'm like wait
a minute i'm feeling that anxiety i know
i'm not gonna get this work done
if i just sit down for 15 minutes i
won't be a procrastinator
and all of this emotional baggage that i
thought is part of myself will go away
and it did
that's just it's just funny have you
ever done a personality test
uh intj oh god whatever
sorry that that's my like that it
shouldn't even be my i didn't even have
like a cover for that reaction that was
just my absolutely
should i say oh i'm sorry let me speak
more on your level i'm a cancer
oh my god that's so much worse
okay stop please please i'm just being
um
anyway maybe after this i'll send you my
dad has a personality test
and it's based on the big big five it's
different than the myers-briggs
it's more scientifically accurate
okay that's not saying much it's good
it's really good i think you'll like it
yeah i know i believe
i'd like something more scientific than
mine yeah yeah no no no i get that i
tried that one it doesn't it doesn't
work the science is not there
i think so i don't know what i am but um
i'll send you this one after the podcast
it's cool okay yeah i'll definitely take
it
you'd come in and low in politeness
disagreeableness
it measures yes very low very low i'm
low i'm zero
zero percentile it's
a very good filter uh when i meet people
i will throw out a
very quickly inappropriate comment and
right away you can tell who you're
dealing with
because they'll roll their eyes which is
fine which is an acknowledgement but not
they're not going to humor my
inappropriateness the people or they'll
go with it yes and
comedic types those are people you get
along with it's the ones who pitch a fit
you're like i can't work with this
person because they're rich in their
behavior
that's a very quick way yeah it's a very
quick uh and because it'll be improv
they'll have to give you their genuine
response
and they don't realize you're doing it
and they just think and because of
my i have enough stature that i can get
away with being a dick sometimes
that's that's a really good idea
i should do i don't do that at all i do
this i don't know it might be different
for females
oh yeah it probably is it might be
it it probably is it's it's weird my
dad's got a lot of like uh
i wouldn't say anti-women
because he's not anti-woman at all but
he he doesn't uh
i think acknowledge sometimes the
difficulties women have compared to men
and i've noticed them um particularly
being married because i have like
a close relationship with a man and now
i can kind of understand understand it
from that angle
but some things are easier and one of
the things that i find
are easier particularly me it's like i'm
on instagram i've got blonde hair so
nobody takes me seriously plus i put up
bikini photos which doesn't help
but um you get taken more seriously by
everybody
if you're a man period and then it
really depends on
like how you look as a woman how serious
you're taken like if you're
older and you dress more conservatively
you're you're taken more
seriously and if you're a man dressing
differently matters but
you're just taking more seriously even
on the phone even if you're talking to
women it's not like women aren't playing
into that
but it's tough sometimes like not tough
like it's you know mildly irritating
compared to
other things i i also think the
feminists are absolutely right that
women
are the subjects of more vitriol on
social media
and the vitriol tends to be more
gendered and
uh in both in intensity and in uh
quantity
uh than males have to deal with um and
it's
to hand wave this away i think is does
no one any good
huh where have you seen that you've just
seen that on social justice
because i'll still have followers of
mine and see how people go after them
right and the the terms people use if
it's someone who's identifiably male
versus identifiably female
or the the speed with which the
aggression escalates
uh after enough time you know you kind
of notice these patterns and it's like
okay
uh so you know when females talk about
this then
then if they you know say this is an
issue then they're shouted down like oh
no one has it easy sure no one has it
easy but doesn't mean that
everyone has it equally uneasy um so
that this is something i've noticed and
and i don't know why it's so um uh i i
think people are so
knee-jerk opposed to kind of giving
feminism any quarter because it's used
often as a cudgel
that they will react instinctively to
any kind of expression
of female vulnerability with any sense
of obligation to compensate for this in
some way
hmm interesting okay well i i agree
it is tougher in some ways um
okay your book the new right
yeah yes what was that about i have
ideas i haven't read any of your books
because i just found out about you and
then reached out and invited you on the
podcast
you keep saying that you don't need to
say it four times it's been like at
least four times like five
maybe but the new right stop
laughing at me i could be yelling
is that better no i just turned the
volume down on my computer though that
wouldn't bother me
i wouldn't be able to see it as much
um the new right what is it i can guess
i think can let me guess first actually
okay
i and i could be totally off because
like i said
i haven't read the book but or heard it
but um is it i don't even know why i'm
doing this because i'm probably off but
is it talking about how the political
right
now has changed um in regards
well in my experience because i used to
be considered
well i've always been like
libertarianism oh and i want to get into
the fact that you're
you're an anarchist right i am yeah
i almost don't even want to continue
with where i was going i don't want to
continue with where i was going okay
anarchy
why on earth would you assume that
that's a good idea
because it's true it corresponds to
reality that no one has the right to
uh assert authority over another human
being without their consent
okay that is true but you also talked
about how vapid people are so wouldn't
you assume that
theoretically in a i'm
there's been a lot of raqqa
little involved you know i can edit this
i'm not going to but i could just cut
that entire thing
but i won't i'm a libertarianist just
like ann rand
i'm going to keep this because i choose
to
anyway everything i say from now on just
doesn't matter
but my assumption is the vapid people
you were talking about
wouldn't it be good if somebody could be
in charge that
actually cared about other people and
was smart and could make decisions
and then they just made decisions that
were better
but also let people have as much freedom
as they wanted
yeah so that is what you're describing
is anarchy so
the vast majority of people are ballast
socially balanced they're not really
in nazi germany they would have been
nazis in iran right now they'll be
yeah muslims in america they'll be
boomers they they will accept the edicts
of their master culture unthinkingly
and proudly and then will fight for it
very vociferously
so under an anarchist system it would be
the same thing however things would be
cheaper
they would have more options and there'd
be more opportunity
for people to create and innovate
because let me give it let's suppose
there is some
there's two ways to do something through
force meaning the state or through
freedom meaning the markets
so let's suppose there's an issue on the
table if i
uh delegate it to the state that means i
have one agency
uh whoever those people are they have to
sit down and figure out the problem
whereas if it's decided in a free system
then literally anyone
millions if it's going to be a nation
billions if it's the world
you have billions of minds trying to
solve this issue
which means the odds that someone will
find if not a solution
even a mere improvement will be
millions and billions of times higher
than it would be under a state
issue so anarchism the arguments for
anarchy are the same
arguments as against the single-payer
healthcare system
it's the same arguments against a
single-payer justice system or a
single-payer security system
the logic follows suit in every way
okay but don't you think it's
unrealistic to expect on anarchy to work
out
like wouldn't some some like macho man
would just take over like it's not
sustainable you'd end up with fascism
instantly the mafia would just like
there'd just be a hierarchy
and then the mafia would take over and
then it'd be north korea
that's what i assume the the
what are presented as the strongest
arguments against anarchism
are inevitably descriptions of the
status quo you are regarding the state
from an anarchist perspective the
republicans and democrats
are literally rival gangs which simply
wear
different colors and have their turf
warfare and they will yell at
each other in front of you and laugh at
you behind your back
so what you're saying the strongest
person will assert their dominance
is in fact what is the case now if you
try not to get your protection money
from the irs
see what happens to you and your
property under an anarchist system there
would not be this centralized
force you would have competition and you
would be able to switch from let's
suppose sprint to at
t as who is your protection service
provider
just as easily as switching cell phones
and this would
discourage uh some this kind of brute
use of force
because no one wants to see that in
their neighborhoods and in fact
every nation is in a state of anarchy
toward every other nation
and they have in fact worked it out
amicably uh
for the most part okay i i do see where
you're coming from
i don't know if i i don't know if i
agree i do see where you're coming
either maybe maybe i still think like
ideally
the problem with politics in general i
have to say one more thing
you also said it's unrealistic what is
really unrealistic
is that the constitution will work as
we've been promised despite 220 years of
data to the contrary
so the constitution has been utterly
ineffective at protecting
gun rights for example whereas gun
distribution and gun proliferation is
the best protection of gun rights as
opposed to some piece of paper
which no one uh follows with any kind of
literalism
okay no that's fair but but
uh so so in the last like i haven't been
home in six months and i've been living
like between russia and serbia
um which were fun for like a week and a
half and i'm not saying i mean i was in
russia in the winter so
that obviously played a factor and i do
like serbia but there are
parts of north america that i like
desperately miss and one of the things
and just something simple is
i can't ship anything here like if i
ship something here
it requires four serbian forms to fill
out
and then they ask for a third
the customs fee is a third of whatever i
purchased and if it's a gift you just
can't get it
so you have to have a form that shows
what you bought
then you need to pay them in cash a
third of the amount
of the purchase and that's just how it
works here and i didn't know that when i
first arrived i assumed it was like
north america and you can just ship
things
so i bought a couple of things and i
can't get them because
you can't ship things here so i i feel
like and maybe this doesn't have
anything to do with politics but i feel
like the way north america is set up
like some of the underpinnings
are done so well that there are things
we don't even have to think about like
shipping things to ourselves
i i think that's funny that you said
this is an example i'm looking it up
right now i
ordered serbian aftershave in
where did i play on ebay i ordered it on
uh may uh hold on where did i wear this
from may 10th
it still hasn't gotten here because the
brand name is called tobacco
and the scent was wild so tobacco is the
brand of the aftershave there's tobacco
wild and tobacco magic still haven't
gotten it here
um we actually have had an example of an
anarchist post office
in the states there's someone named
lysandra spooner who is a great
abolitionist hero great anarchist hero
and he had a private post office and his
argument was
just because the constitution allows for
the government to establish a post
office
does not mean it forbids private
competition and his competitive post
office was
cheaper and more efficient than the u.s
postal service
so of course they sued him until they
drove him out of business i have just
recently i bought an ebay
a letter with one of his stamps on it
that was used in the 18
i think 40s so that was pretty cool um
but
i don't think either these the us or
serbia are particular examples they're
just different types of
status mixed economies so you're saying
the us could be better oh absolutely
basically
a lot better well that's not saying a
lot right now
i think we're doing good of course
really oh yeah
very hot plate i have been optimistic
absolutely of course you're not
you think things are going bad i don't
know i've just written off 2020 joe
rogan just posted or
i don't know what he re instagrammed
that there were alien
spaceships like i'm done with 20 20. i'm
done i told you
you joked about astrology i'm almost at
the point where i'm looking to
astrologists for answers
wait why is it bad that there's ufos if
that were true
why would any alien come here and like
help us
why wouldn't they just exterminate
everybody plus we're annoying
wait i i you uh man you canadians i
thought you were supposed to be all nice
and polite
i'm not like i'm zero percentile
okay you've blocked everybody annoying
on twitter and you [ __ ]
trying to kill them you you told people
you told me people were
vapid but you don't think they're
annoying just vapid no no
no no no i'm sorry that's not the leap
the leap isn't from that's annoying the
leaf is from annoying to exterminate
that's the leaf i said aliens would
exterminate i don't wanna
know no but you're saying you would
empathize with the population
that wanted to exterminate an annoying
race
yeah yeah jesus like
termites that you want termites in your
house no
you move into a new house what if you
move into a new house that's already
occupied by termites don't you
exterminate them what if they view us
like termites i don't even know why
we're on this topic but that's that's
what i'm saying that's literally a fair
concept did you know that
no he said i'm not an anti-semite of
anti-termite you probably should edit
out this little section because this is
i've been in eastern europe for way too
long
it's like a week a week i was like oh
this is great there are lights
everywhere and then i could see
yeah huh i i don't think um
we don't know that they're if they're
manned these ships
and uh it was stephen hawking the late
great physicist who did make the point
that like we shouldn't be so
uh eager to have interstellar contact
because if you look at the history of
american explorers
you know it it doesn't always end up
being so nice for the population that is
pioneered right well what are they going
to do like make all this work
traveling around and then they're going
to come and help us like
really well i guess like maybe
but it seems very unlikely but didn't
you but you truly
i mean you traveled to eastern europe to
get help
yeah i know that but like one of the
doctors here was literally literally
looked at us and was like
why are you here literally
and we were like cause north america is
not great for something
sorry please please help us but le that
was a question it was why are you here
dead serious i was like oh [ __ ] i don't
know
[Laughter]
2020 is gonna get better for you i
promise i'm telling you really
yeah according to the astrologers it's
not well we're gonna fight okay good
this is gonna be a scientific test i'm
telling you it's going to get be good
between now and december
the astrologers say no we're going to
check in in january 1st
okay and that's whatever's wrong gets to
exterminate the other one
and their family i'm not into
exterminating or as
generational punishment no we agreed
no way will we feed them to the lions
okay well i want to wrap this up yes but
that was really fun thank you i needed
some laughs so much
that was yeah so thank you for coming on
and um where can people find you
i'm not i'm like aids i'm everywhere
twitter.com michael vallis is probably
the best bet
[Music]
you